there's a moment when you're just a fan
and there's a moment when you're a
filmmaker
and the one moment can follow the other
by about one minute
i've been directing films for almost
four decades and i've picked up a few
things along the way
for the first time ever i'll share some
of the things that i haven't shared
before
really every filmmaker starts as a fan
i get my ideas the same place everybody
gets their ideas out of your imagination
i can't emphasize enough
the importance of curiosity every film
you've ever watched
every book you've ever read every dream
you've ever had
before you can radiate you need to
absorb
it's a creativity law of thermodynamics
in this master class i'm going to talk
about storytelling suspense
action visual effects design all the
things you're going to need to know
so i'm going to show a scene right now
and then i'll go back and break it down
the thing that it's important to
remember about the terminator is that
it's a love story their eyes made across
a crowded room it's a love story with
shotguns
and my goal with avatar was to have
people dream with their eyes wide open
i feel like i'm there it looks real
but it has to be a dream when i started
out i was working as a truck driver
didn't have much
spare cash certainly couldn't afford
film school but all you have to do is
pick up a camera and start shooting
something
with the intention of making a film and
you're a filmmaker
and i think it's the duty of filmmakers
that have been down the roadways
to turn around and say all right there's
a land mine over here
there's a landmine over here don't step
on it so why not share that
i'm james cameron and this is my master
class
[Music]
you